Emmanuel Macron vous a écrit une lettre
vous et aux autres chefs de parti hier
soir il confirme qu'il est favorable à
un élargissement du référendum notamment
aux questions migratoires est-ce que
c'est une bonne chose ben vous avez
compris dans la droite ligne de ce que
je viens de vous dire qu'il y a un appel
non pas d'air un appel du pied au
Républicain qui le réclame à cor et à
cri comme le RN et donc il est là pour
leur dire je vais vous satisfaire et je
vais vous donner ce nouveau gage de ma
confiance et donc en retour j'espère
votre confiance mais ce deal là je n'y
participerai jamais surtout si vous avez
lu le texte qu'il nous a envoyé c'est
quand même assez extraordinaire il nous
dit je suis prêt à un référendum sur
l'immigration mais alors par contre sur
les super profits réforme fiscale ça
c'est pas possible et puis puisque en
fait il faut aller jusqu'au bout vous
voulez vous un référendum sur la
retraite et bien je vous dis c'est
impossible aussi on ne pourra pas
toucher en fait à la réforme des
retraites avant 5 ans voilà ce que nous
dit Emmanuel Macron donc la ficelle est
grosse c'estd les référendum pour la
droite et l'extrême droite j'y suis
favorable les référendum que propose la
gauche sur les super profits ou sur la
réforme des retraites alors là c'est
impossible écoutez la ficelle est trop
grosse pour que je participe à cette
mascarade mais est-ce que ça veut dire
que vous n'irez pas à la prochaine
rencontre de saintnille 17 je je ne
pense pas enfin effectivement quand je
vois en fait ce que nous écrit le chef
de l'État laissant penser que
aujourd'hui il y aurait une forme de
nouveau scénacle qu' aurait qu' l'urait
inventé alors le Parlement on n parle
plus toute façon il marche au 493 mais
vous avez pendant ce temps-là en fait
une espèce de cénacle qui serait avec
quelques apifu avec quelques privilégiés
qui auraient la chance de parler avec le
chef de l'État les chefs de parti qui
feraient leur tambouille entre eux mais
c'est
non c'est non parce que je ne veux pas
supprimer le Parlement je crois à la
démocratie je crois au fait que en fait
il y a des lieux où on puisse voter dans
ces rendez-vous que le chef de l'État
nous n'avons jamais y compris voter nous
sommes simplement là pour donner un avis
et après il essaie de faire croire que
ayant donné notre avis il a réussi à
trouver une synthèse qu'il produirait
devant les Français et que qui serait le
résultat d'un consensus global entre
nous mais il n'y a jamais eu de
consensus sur aucun sujet d'ailleurs et
c'est bien naturel parce que la
démocratie c'est de pouvoir faire des
choix et moi je ne veux pas laisser
penser que désormais il n'y a plus de
choix il y aurait plus qu'un seul choix
possible c'est président de la
République donc ça c'est pas possible
donc vous n'irez pas pourtant vous êtes
allé à la précédente rencontre mais je
suis un républicain et donc quand je
suis invité par le chef de l'État à une
première démarche qui nous dit écoutez
je voudrais discuter avec vous je vais
pas refuser de discuter maintenant quand
je vois quel est l'ordre du jour qui
nous est proposé venir valider en fait
le deal qu'il veut passer avec la droite
et l'extrême droite pardon mais enfin je
ne suis pas là pour tenir la chandelle
donc je ne ferai pas en fait euh office
de je ne sais quoi donc voilà il y a pas
de possibilité pour moi s'il veut se
marier avec la droite et pousser le
raisonnement jusqu'à l'extrême droite
grand bien lui fasse ce sera sans moi
merci Olivier fort merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin on
passe au club des
territoires